foreign
how do you move on from lots of horrible
past things there's been abuse in the
past like physical or emotional abuse in
the past or one or both of you have
cheated on each other and y'all want to
move on which one is it some of all of
Olive stick
[Music]
this is John with the Dr John deloney
show
so glad you've joined us happy New Year
hope you're doing well hope it is not
freezing Wherever You Are
uh
I looked for the low for tomorrow or two
days from now three
three
unacceptable
unacceptable
uh for a Texas kid that makes me
reconsider whether hell is hot
I think hell will be very very cold but
alas
um hope your your winter is is going
well hope you're having a happy New Year
and we are glad you you joined us on the
greatest mental health podcast of all
time ever if you want to be on the show
go to John deloney.com ask and thank you
thank you thank you for your five star
reviews for hitting the Subscribe button
please don't forget to hit the Subscribe
button it's a gift to your neighbors it
just spins the show up in the algorithms
and it has been spinning up quite quite
a lot so thank you so so much um don't
forget to share these episodes all right
let's go to Rose in Lansing Michigan
what's up Rose
hi good morning
what's up
um you never hear that do you I'm sorry
wherever you are all right sorry I got
that out of my system all right okay
what's up okay so tell me what's up
um okay okay
um wow I'm sorry
my singing tends to do that to people
it's not great
I I think it's just fine it's not I
wanted to be a metal singer growing up
that's all I wanted to be in the world I
wanted to be this really tough cool
metal singer and I'm a YouTuber so
clearly my singing is not great but alas
alright so this call is about you not
not my failed attempts to be cool so
what's up
um well I guess I'll just get to it
um
my um question is how do you move on
from
past
lots of horrible past things
and um
just change your life and
get your marriage
back to or I guess we
redo your marriage
foreign
this is probably the top two or three
Vegas conversations I've ever had it's
it's incredible how do you you
know that stuff that they yeah okay so
um sorry all right here's it's one of
two things and I'm only this is this is
just I've had this conversation so many
times either
um there's been abuse in the past like
physical or emotional abuse in the past
and y'all are still
you you are your spouse is as forgiven
the other person and you want to move on
or one or both of you have cheated on
each other and y'all want to move on
which one is it or tell me I'm wrong
um some of all of that oh geez Louise on
a stick okay so how long have y'all been
married
uh we've been married seven years okay
and tell me first about the
physical and emotional abuse
um well thankfully not physical okay
but emotional
um on both sides we've just
in the beginning of our marriage just
very immature and
thankfully we're coming out of that okay
but and
um when did the infidelity start
um
on his side
[Applause]
probably
I don't know maybe a year or two in and
then my side
I'd say
let's see it'd be three years ago
but that had started okay with what did
you fall for somebody or was it multiple
partners
um you just started dating around behind
his back
um one was an online thing and then a uh
physical one which was
about a year ago two years okay does he
know about it
he does yes and do you know about his
yes yeah we uh
shared it all okay how did y'all come to
how did y'all land there like that's x
marks the spot how did y'all both decide
we're just gonna put all this on the
table
what brought you there
um
we asked the receptionists we truly
wanted to make this work and the only
way to move forward is to share it all
was our decision okay and what was
what was the result of that hard
conversation
did you both did you know he'd been
cheating on you and he knew you've been
cheating on him or was it a shock to
both of you or
um um we both know okay
yeah
okay
how long ago was that how long ago was
that conversation
hmm
uh I'd say two years ago
so what's changed in the last two years
or do you find yourself right back in
the same spot
uh thankfully not in the same spot we're
just I don't know I I feel
like I'm constantly
tortured by my past
your pastor has passed
I guess both
random thoughts will come off of
remembering
what he's done and then remembering what
I've done and then hating myself for it
I want to um I want to for the sake of
the listener and for the sake of clarity
in this conversation and there's a point
to me doing this okay
um
I want to drill down into what you just
said Just Thoughts of
do you have images in your head that pop
in of him
being sexually involved with another
woman
do you have do you have moments when
you're taking a shower you're sitting by
yourself in the car or school on
Instagram and you think of physically
being with this other guy and it makes
you smile or makes your heart beat
faster and then you feel sick about it
uh yes yeah okay
is that
is that the stuff that you thought would
be gone by now
like I yeah I'm trying to get from there
to
you have these thoughts you're y'all are
working on it you're putting your
marriage back together you're building
something new
and yet these thoughts keep popping into
your head and you thought they would be
gone by now
is that what we're getting at
uh yes though there is another
complication to store here there always
is go for it well I guess I say two you
can't get to them as quickly as you can
because yes like we're taking a long
time to circle the plane around the uh
The Landing Strip true sorry no it's all
good it's all good
um so
who I cheated on my husband was
physically was my brother-in-law
and I had a child with him
here here
yeah
so
it's more complicated
that may be the understatement of the
day
yeah it definitely is it's been the
Vegas most understated uh so
that was your sister's husband
uh no uh that'd be my husband's sister's
husband
which they're now divorced yeah I would
I would just guess so I would guess yeah
um man that makes Thanksgiving awkward
huh
uh yeah though I mean nobody talks about
it
but yeah
do they not see the little kid running
around
um they do
but I mean he looks enough like me I
don't know
okay the dysfunction here is
multi-leveled how can I help what do you
uh and you said there was one more
what's what's the one more is there
another one after that
oh just the
this side of the family my side of the
family just that cool yeah okay so how
can I how can I help
um well I mean
just moving on forward I just
I just I feel lost at what to do
um
like should this
be out in the open and then we'd
probably never go over to his family or
see any of them
um I don't know they don't know
and now
I mean I'm sure they have speculations
but your sister-in-law doesn't know that
it was you or she just doesn't tell
anybody
she just doesn't tell anyone yeah I I
don't believe that for less than half a
second
I'm sure she's told multiples yes I'm
confident that everybody knows and for
the sake of your husband everybody is
and this little baby everybody's trying
to keep the peace
and I'm guessing that this isn't the
only sideways
meth and banjo's things going on in this
family lineage and so I I don't I don't
I that doesn't strike me they're
probably like well geez you know what I
mean so right
um at this point here's the deal at this
point your husband has made some
your husband chose to violate your
marriage covenant the thing you all
agreed on you said I do forever he
violated that you violated that
as a consequence of that violation now
you have another child
another marriage is destroyed okay and
I'm not gonna put that all on you and
put that on him
all of that sounds so complicated and it
feels like the smoke is so thick it's
really not
and one of my favorite things to do is
to sit down in a situation like this
with somebody when everything feels like
it's on fire and to actually unwind it
because it's not really what you have
before you is a s is a
repeated series of small steps that's
going to be the next six months the next
one year the next five years the next 25
years of your life
and that is choosing to do the next
right thing
that is intentionally having once a week
or for for right now maybe twice or
three times a week Monday Wednesday and
Friday
30 minute check-ins with your husband
how are you how are you feeling
a commitment to him
and him to you that there will be no
more secrets
that means you might have to for a
season be like man I thought about you
and so and so today and I
immediately tossed it out of my mind
um or I had a hard week just remembering
things that I've done I had a hard
remembering things that you've done it
was just tough or I looked up so and so
on social media today and I just had
like a moment of weakness and I screwed
up and I'm feeling bad about it
and he can't fix you all he can say is
thank you for sharing that and you can't
fix him and all you can say is thank you
for sharing that but we're practicing
not having Secrets anymore which just
means we're practicing telling the truth
which means we're practicing
vulnerability which means now we're
practicing how to be married
see that
right yeah and you gotta have a daily
choice to a not be naive
because you've cheated on him once and
you'll you might do it again and vice
versa and
I have to choose every time that thought
lightning bolts into my mind I have to
choose to have another thought ready to
go
and not dwell on it both the the ones
that make you want to throw up thinking
of him with another woman
and the ones that make your heart beat a
little bit faster and make the you smile
a little bit you with another guy
is that fair
that is fair you have to choose not to
entertain those and if you don't make
that choice you're just gonna be
choosing to bring fog into your marriage
on a daily basis and for everyone
listening this goes for everybody who
has romantic Partners from the Past who
um had almost affairs with that person
at work but you didn't at the last
minute right
those when we have other people that
make us feel alive and this is every
single marriage everybody I've ever met
in my life I don't know anybody I'm not
I'm not I'm not uh excluded from this
old memories pop into your mind
feelings pop into your into your heart
like this person laughed at my jokes
this person made me feel comfortable
this person made me feel warm and my
person I'm married to my girlfriend my
boyfriend whoever doesn't make me feel
that today
and so your body goes looking for it and
it remembers it and you have to have
enough discipline to say I'm not going
to
get my fix from somebody from my past
I'm not going to get my fix from
somebody who's not my spouse I'm gonna
intentionally not do this
and that's hard man it's hard right
yeah definitely is
um and then you are gonna have to
balance
this violation you made right you
violated your core values in your
Covenant and you got this amazing
wonderful child Fair
fair so you're gonna have to there's
just gonna be a tension there and trying
to feel like that tension doesn't exist
or pretend that tension doesn't exist is
a waste of your time and energy
because it's always going to be the best
worst thing that ever happened to you
right
have you said it out loud you slept with
your sister-in-law's husband
that happened you did that with a period
you shouldn't have done that can we
agree on that
yes definitely and you have an amazing
young kid how old's this baby uh he's
one okay is he incredible is he
hilarious funny silly quiet who tell me
about him
he is a complete goofball good good
sounds like he's falling after his mom
right
absolutely crazy good
um we're gonna honor this little kid and
at the same time we're not going to
shroud this thing in shame
um going to family events and pretending
like things didn't happen is
it
that's the curse of generations
it's the fog that hangs over every get
together it's the black smoke that
covers up I mean that is in the air of
every interaction between family members
and at some point your husband it's his
family he's got to step up and say hey
this happened this is and this is what
we're doing about it we're raising this
kid it's gonna be great do you have any
contact with the other guy
oh he just ran off
okay so you have 100 full custody
yes yeah yeah has your husband adopted
this kid
um under the law here he just
automatically became the full Guardian
okay I would get with somebody and make
sure that's written down make sure
that's in some sort of paperwork so that
this other dude didn't pop back up
um okay in the future
um here's what I want you guys to to sit
down and ask and this is the new year
and this is a great time to start this
how can you encourage life in your
husband here's what I mean by that
what makes him feel alive
when you hold his hand watching a TV
show going dancing when he's out farming
or hunting I don't know what he does or
fixing stuff I don't know who this dude
is but what makes him feel alive and how
can you contribute to that to breathing
life into his life
and vice versa
how can he
give you life how can he breathe life
into your life that might be as simple
as helping around the house with with
dishes and babies and diapers and stuff
like that that could be taking you out
once a week that could be planning for a
big vacation once a year that could be
working four jobs to pay off any money
your family owes to other people because
you can't breathe it could be meeting
Monday Wednesday Friday to make sure
you're being intentional and make sure
your marriage is staying on this very
wobbly track that it's on right now
foreign
but how do how do you breathe life into
his life into his world and how does he
breathe life into your world that's the
question you are asking
and this is going to take both of you
taking a knee because y'all have both
been really really selfish and you've
both been really really immature and now
you got kids and now it's time to grow
up is that fair
yeah yeah
okay are you in
I'm in
how can I help that Journey do you have
my books and and all the gear
I I don't okay so I want you to hang on
the line I'm going to send you a copy of
both redefining anxiety and own your
past change your future which my two
best-selling books and I'm gonna send
you both decks of questions for humans
for couples and this is just going to be
a way for you and your husband to have
conversations together I've already done
the work for you I've already asked a
question you just have to pull these
cards out when you all are having some
some private time together not with kids
running around everywhere
whether it's gel on the front porch
whether it's all in the bedroom whether
Joe out on a date bring these cards and
this is just going to be a way to
introduce Humanity
for God's sake
don't cheat
period
and especially don't cheat with family
members
no more no more
thank you for being brave and for your
call we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode's sponsor betterhelp
hey look there's a lot of things we
don't get to choose on this wild ride
called life right the neighbor's kid
learning to play Trombone weird things
trending on the tick tocks or whatever
that is we don't get to choose the
weather but when you realize how much
you do have a choice in it's so
empowering check this out you get to
decide who you want to be I get to ask
myself the question who do I want to be
you get to choose who speaks into your
life and you get to choose to pursue
meaningful relationships this is
life-changing stuff but I'll be honest
it's not easy these are new skills that
we all have to learn and therapy is a
great place to practice these new skills
and that's why I love better help better
help is Affordable online therapy that
can match you with a therapist quickly
and it lets you switch any time to make
sure it's the right fit and just like
in-person therapy it can help equip you
with the tools you need to work towards
being who you want to be because you
don't just have to let life happen to
you you can take it head on so visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go to Lauren
in Gainesville Florida what's up Lauren
hey how we doing
I'm doing well how are you excellent
excellent so what's up
um so I kind of wrote down just the gist
of it
um so I am a special education teacher
and have been at my current school for
about three years now I love my
classroom my students I love working
with the other adults in my classroom
however about a month ago I had to
report two of my co-workers to my
Administration as well as DCF for things
that I saw and heard them do towards a
child who is non-verbal and autistic
what'd they do I know I did
um I don't know how much I can really
say
um but it was just something out at the
playground
um and it dealt with
um a potential video of a student
um showing some private parts
um I didn't know if there was a video
and so that's why I kind of had to
report it
um but also I heard some things about
some retaliation of why that student was
so upset in the first place by a
different teacher
um and then my principal is actually the
one to tell me to report it to DCF
um there there wasn't an investigation
with BCF but the school did an
investigation and then they basically
just returned back to school about
um three or four days after the incident
so was the finding
that you thought something really bad
had happened turns out something really
bad didn't happen no part no harm no
foul or did the school find things and
sweep it under the rug
I don't know I never knew anything about
what the investigation you know resulted
in
um sometimes depending on and again I
don't know your state and I don't know
whether you're in a union all that kind
of stuff but often the complaintant has
a written response that comes to them
okay that makes sense so if you if you
um and I know this is especially an
assault um investigations if you
complained about something
um you made a complaint I say
complaining like you're whining not like
that but you you made a complaint that
somebody
um
uh sexually assaulted you or was had
inappropriate contact with you
you would get after a certain amount of
time 30 days 60 days 90 days you would
get a written report of the findings
even from like the school district yes
okay I don't know if that applies in
Florida I don't know if that applies in
your particular District especially to a
report like this
why didn't the school district I mean
why didn't uh
what it's CPS from from Texas what's it
called there
DCF DCF why did they not do any sort of
Investigation
um they just kind of send an email after
saying that there wasn't enough to go
about it okay to look further into it
okay based on based on what I was
telling them okay cool so I'm guessing
you're a pariah now
um yes yes
and that's basically my question
um because like I know I did the right
thing everyone has told me that um I did
what my Administration told me to do
um but not just from the two people
um but
my whole kind of special education
preschool team
um pretty much will either tell me that
I did the wrong thing or when I say hi
to them in the hallways they just stare
at me and ignore me
um my actual like para paraprofessionals
in my classroom they are on my side if
you will
um and so we're just kind of in our own
little classroom and the other couple of
classrooms they do their holiday party
without us they
um kind of just stay on their side so
it's kind of getting a little lonely
absolutely and a bit awkward yeah
because you're the snitch now Lauren
yes geez Louise Okay so
here's a perfect world
a perfect world as you see something
like that
and in your mind some a couple of
teachers are taking advantage sexually
explicit videos of a student with
special needs any student
and they're laughing about it they're
making jokes about it and you
immediately flip your lid as you should
as any adult with a pulse should and you
report that your principal tells you to
report it they come back and turns out
it was the whole thing was uh
misunderstanding in no way was what was
what you thought was happening actually
happening then those adults come to you
and they're like hey what happened why'd
you report us and you say man because of
this and this and they're like oh geez
I totally get it hey thank God you care
this much about students young people
children
and that's not what happened at all in
the future just holler at us dude and
we'll be we'll be the first to tell you
and there would be some sort of uh we
talked about on the show probably about
a year ago there was a dad who was
walking out of like a TJ Maxx or
something and his little child was doing
a temper tantrum right and then the guy
walking in stopped
and the dad said Thank God somebody
stopped even though my kids don't temper
Tantra when I'm just getting out of the
store I'm glad that somebody cared
enough to stop that's what I hope that's
the way I hope adults Act
you know what I mean
um and if I didn't do anything wrong I
shouldn't care about an investigation I
want to care about that I didn't do
anything so that's how it would I would
hope it works in a perfect world we
don't live in that world we live in a
world where it's I told my son the other
day who's in seventh grade he's like I
can't wait till middle school's over and
I was like I got I got to break some bad
news to you brother this is the rest of
your life when people will be like oh my
gosh what are you wearing why are you
wearing this is how you cut your hair oh
my gosh that's gonna be the rest of your
life and so
you've heard me say not by your hand but
in your lap you were minding your
business at work and all of a sudden you
saw something that was the core epitome
of evil you reported it you did the
right thing you didn't do anything about
I mean you didn't cause any of this but
it landed in your lap you responded to
it
and now you have to own the consequences
of having done the right thing which
often are miserable
yes right and so it sounds like the
choices you have before you
already go to another school
or to make peace with I did the right
thing and it at the end of the day my
Integrity wins out and over a long
enough period of time
people will make their way back to
somebody who is of character
you tell me I can't tell you to quit
your job
I know but you said the L word you said
you're lonely and I hate that word
and part of me doesn't want to see
somebody like a group of immature
bullies win
by you leaving
the other side of it is
um I don't
I don't want you to have an already more
miserable life than you got right now
for doing the right thing
if you're trying to love and care for
kids
yeah you know what I mean and so there's
the old saying you know Jay-Z's like
just brush your shoulders off dude or
you know Jesus like dust her sandals off
like I'm out there's a part of me that's
just like I'm out
like if this is how it's gonna be man
for me doing the right thing then
God bless you all have fun and I'm just
gonna think a second thing of it
um what's Magic about this place that
you don't want to leave
or is it just the principle of
um no it's mostly just um the people in
my classroom
classroom to stay in my classroom for
next year that they don't want to go to
these other classrooms
um you know because they probably have
absolutely little to no influence over
that
um well that's where our principal is
actually pretty cool like we do
um put forth what we kind of want and
she usually tries to keep it how um we
kind of request it to her
um we kind of do have some say over what
students we have in our classrooms and
um what adults have you gone to talk to
your teacher I mean your principal and
asked to say hey man things are really
awful is there
I don't know if they've got any ideas or
they can bring people together or go for
a retreat or some some way to heal some
of this
um but it may just be adults acting like
adults and it's just hard I mean adults
acting like children that's just hard
yeah they had um I brought it up kind of
within the first couple of days because
it was a lot worse
um people were a lot more obvious and
some names were being called and so they
had brought in and kind of talked about
it since then it's more of a
professional ignoring
um if you will they put it on you like
you be the grown-up and just going about
your day
there's so hey
good for that there's something to be
said for dude I'm like I'm gonna come
here and love these students take care I
got a core group of professionals that
work with me that we're we're a great
team I'm gonna love these kids and I'm
gonna go home man
some of that is Shifting your
expectations on what the workplace is
supposed to provide to you I'm gonna get
my friendships and my community and my
connections outside of here I also know
the reality for a special ed teacher
um I taught in a co-taught classroom
uh for a couple years there's multiple
adults in that classroom you it you have
to rely on the community outside you're
there at 7 00 a.m you leave at 7 00 p.m
you're there all day right
um that's your world man and it's no
good when you can't walk down the hall
and say hi and people just go like we're
on Mean Girls part two or something like
that so
uh I I can't tell you because I don't
live in your situation and I wouldn't
tell you whether you quit or not
I don't see it as a failure I don't see
it as a moral you're somehow less of
character if you leave
that's you just saying I want to have a
better life
I did the right thing y'all can be
immature I want to have a better life
and good special ed teachers are so hard
to come by you will have another job
before you can you can blink
I also don't have any problem with you
trying to Crest above it
I'm gonna continue to be nice and smile
and wave
and if y'all want to continue to give me
the silence treatment it's not treatment
like we're in sixth grade then you're
welcome you're welcome to burden
yourselves with that I'm not gonna do
that I'm going to continue to love kids
be a great professional be a great
colleague and if I see something else
that I think is abusive I'm gonna reach
out I'm gonna do it every single time
so um sorry you're in this in this in
this pickle man it's no fun but I'm
really proud of you for doing the hard
thing following your gut even though hey
it may not it ended up there was nothing
actionable here what was what you
thought was happening wasn't happening
I still applaud your bravery for seeing
something
and saying something
all of us could do that a little bit
more thank you so much for the call
we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only not available in all
states or locations
all right we are back
is it D or die
that's incredible
die from Washington DC
yes that's me in can I tell you
something hilarious
um in college I had a roommate from a
Tiny Town in Kansas that was amazing
he's one of my best friends in the world
still
but he listened to like Tony Toni Toni
and he had like in sync Christmas record
I did not I had lots of Pantera records
so Pantera was coming to town and I'd
seen them a few times and I was like we
got to go to the show
and so he went to the mirror and he
wrote die on his forehead
it was in the mirror so it came out
backwards
oh no and then it was like in permanent
marker and so he had died right on his
head backwards for the whole show oh
gosh and it was awesome and now in any
time I hear the word die it makes me
think of that except that's your name
incredible all right die from Washington
what's up
hey so I am a homeschooling mom of four
kids and I'm actually calling about my
number three today he's nine years old
and he is probably the cutest little guy
you'll ever meet
um he's really funny he's very
light-hearted just a kind kind boy
um but
um he's also super super competitive
like takes it so much to heart and and I
mean in everything it's not just
athletically it's in board games it's in
pickup Sports it's
um he plays baseball so if they lose a
game it's borderline devastating for him
um but the other thing that he is really
competitive and sensitive about is
school and since I'm his teacher
I get the brunt of it and I actually get
to see his reaction to feelings of
failure or losing and so what he does
when he feels frustrated or like he's
just not getting a concept is he will
just turn into this tiny ball of rage
and what that ends up looking like is he
has very negative self-talk he'll go up
to his room and he will scream and at
the top of his lungs he'll yell you know
I'm so stupid I'll never be good at
anything why doesn't anybody like me I'm
so lonely you know things like that just
really devolved into everything that
feels like it's wrong in his life and
depending on how upset he is like what
he's upset about and this is the part
that I'm actually really concerned about
is he will get his nails into his arms
or his his legs until he's either got
really deep bruisy like marks or he's
bleeding
um but like I said outside of school and
sports like things that involve
competition or where he can get
frustrated he's just really he's just
really a good boy and I don't really
know how to manage this because my
husband and I were really intentional
with the kids like finding things to
praise about them shaming and guilting
over Sports school performance that's
just that's not part of who we are or
what we do so I'm really looking like to
understand and then move forward in
helping him deal with these issues in a
more healthy way that's a great question
um I'm going to tell you out of the gate
that I recommend that you take him to a
local play therapist there in Washington
okay okay and um
foreign
off the top of my head here's what it
sounds like how old are your kids
I have a 15 year old 13 year old
nine-year-old and six-year-old okay
so that's quite the Gap
um yeah
I'm gonna rattle off a few things that
it that are just coming to mind okay
um
so we're talking about a kid who is
somewhat disregulated and excessively so
for a nine-year-old okay
um
either
well
that could be a kid who has is quietly
being bullied or abused by an older
sibling or an older sibling's friends
okay
um that is experienced a few things
basically he's got an engine inside of
him that is too big for his little body
to process
okay and normally that engine slowly
opens up over time it happens through
hormones it happens to puberty it
happens through life experiences we call
that wisdom right and that and the the
dream of a parent is that we can walk
alongside our kids in these Milestone
markers as this thing this engine slowly
grows and opens up
if there's sexual abuse at a young age
boom that you have an adult engine
inside of a child body now if there is
bullying that goes on that that
accelerates the opening of the growth of
this engine inside of this little body
and the body it's just like putting a
Ferrari engine inside of a of a of a of
a Prius it the the car can't handle the
the what's under the hood right and so
sometimes it is external behaviors that
have happened to this kid and that's
where that's where a
um number one I want you to your
immediate thought is that's not
happening here that should be your
immediate thought as a good parent okay
yeah yeah and the second thought should
be
something's happening
and I'm gonna go get it checked out okay
do you think that so due to the nature
of my husband's employment we do move
fairly frequently and when I say move
we're moving from state to state do you
think that could be a reason why this
big dysregulation is happening it it I
mean it could be
okay it could be
um
I think
so I could go to the store right now I
have an old I have an old pickup truck I
could go to the store and get six or
seven different types of shocks on my
truck I could get performance shocks
that made I could go over rocks I could
get um like Cruiser shocks that made it
real smooth to drive down the road I
could get jacked up like you know make
my car talk but all those shocks have
different levels of sensitivity to them
our kids are very much the same that's
how you considered a kitchen table and
you tell one joke and three of your kids
start dying laughing and one just goes
into a frenzy and starts like why are
you making fun of me like whoa they they
naturally have a a different level of
sensitivity all four of those shocks
work great they're just they're just
different and so we often try to create
like we have we have kids with different
level sensitivity and you've got that
and that's okay
um in fact that's beautiful and we want
to honor that it just looks different
different context and some things that
may
Empower I've got one kid that if we we
did we moved a lot it made him very
resilient my other kid it would have
been a much bigger challenge
just because there was a sensitivity
there could be that could be that
um it could just like I mentioned it
could be a sensitivity the other thing
could be this when you have four kids
there is somewhat of a Hunger Games for
identity who am I right yes yeah do you
see me hey Mom do you see me do You See
Me Do you see me and this is the the
benefit and the curse of homeschooling
is there is no other adult that can give
your kid praise you have to be the
person
yeah and accidentally not accidentally
it's very naturally
our children gravitate they find a path
towards here's how I'm seen
and sometimes when we catch our kids
being good which you said you and your
husband do which is awesome we all
parents need to spend more time catching
their kids doing great things instead of
pointing out the things that they're
failing at
yeah but
sometimes little younger kids will watch
the praise that older siblings get for
achievement and performance
okay and they will fall into a path of
that's how I get Mom and Dad to love me
and then they're not as good as brother
or sister they're not as fast or as
smart as brother and sister and in their
little Minds The Path towards
connectivity with Mom and Dad has been
blocked because I suck
yeah you see it initially that's exactly
what what I see okay yeah I can totally
see that that resonates a lot with us
because my oldest started college when
she was 12 and is a performance pianist
my next oldest is a p or not a Pianist a
performance guitarist and so they have
these things that they've excelled
incredibly at and he hasn't quite found
it and then Here Comes Daryl and Daryl
loves trucks
right and here's here's the challenge as
a parent Daryl's still awesome
yes and if it wasn't for the Daryl's in
the world princess piano players
couldn't get themselves to and from
practice
that's right right and so the challenge
that you have as a parent is
some very specific one-on-one time
this is a great opportunity for like the
weekly breakfast in the morning that you
do not have time for I understand
yeah but that your kid desperately needs
yes and it may be that once a week mom
and
little Daryl go out for breakfast and
the 15 year old has an opportunity to
teach one of the morning lessons
and we're going to be our dad stays at
home on those mornings but what we're
going to start doing is being very
intentional about relationship because
we want to over time this is not going
to happen overnight is it going to be
like a one two five year Journey you're
on now
we want this
we want this kid to realize there is no
obstruction to any path I take towards
love to Mom
yeah right and yeah
um yeah so and so plays a piano great
my I'll give my dad and mom super props
on this I was a big
um super 5A High School football guy in
in uh in Texas right that's a religion
right my dad wore my letter jacket
around it was a whole thing there was
like seven or eight thousand people that
showed up every Friday to my games it
was it was a Mayhem my brother
went to college on a cello scholarship
and
he was a virtuoso he was incredible
but it was V it was a d i i remember
going to college as my brother was
entering High School thinking I don't
know how my dad's going to toggle this
and he did it masterfully because he
never my brother always
he went to all the concerts he cheered
for him he talked to him about the
performance he made sure he was
practicing he went to my brother's like
rock band shows so it was a my it my dad
and my both my dad and my mom did a
masterful job of never making anybody
feel less than does that make sense and
that just is your goal and man it's
awesome when you can go to church and
talk about well Susie's just won another
national competition playing the piano
and Little Billy is also good
and Daryl loves trucks right it's it
doesn't sound doesn't have a quite ring
to it that's your job as Mom and Dad
but all I have to say is I would
um I would set up an appointment with a
play therapy he's nine I think that
would be a really valuable exercise just
to get an outside perspective and to
rule out
to some things happen behind closed
doors that we didn't know about
is there some bullying going on is there
some abusive Tendencies going on is
there some overly type a older brother
and sister that this nine-year-old is
internalizing as less than like whatever
a great therapist can help ferret some
of that out and it may just be your
nine-year-old sees the older ones and
says oh that's how to get Mom and Dad to
love me
and in a busy house with four little
kids and you're running around and
homeschooling it's real easy to
say way to go you did a great job on
that exam you did a great job on this
thing
and suddenly the kids adopt achievement
as the way to Mom and Dad's heart and
then as parents it's our job to let them
know on a regular basis not just with
words but demonstrating it
[Music]
I'll Always Love You
regardless of what you do regardless of
where you go you've always got a place
here both in my home and in my heart
because you're my kid
[Music]
that's a tough mission for every parent
but that's what we signed up for die
thank you so much for your call thank
you for Evan
easily the best name of anyone who's
ever called into the show and thank you
for caring about all of your kids all of
them we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's only your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
close this one down
I'll let you
decide which saw which which collar this
song applies to it's by The All-American
Rejects
songs called Dirty Little Secret it goes
like this let me know that I've done
wrong
when I've known this all along I go
around a time or two just to waste my
time with you tell me all that you've
thrown away find out games you don't
want to play You're the only one that
needs to know
I'll keep you my dirty little secret
don't tell anyone or you'll just be
another regret
I hope you can keep it my dirty little
secret
they couldn't
don't keep secrets it never works I love
you guys see you soon
[Music]